a new study in the Journal of the
American Heart Association reveals that
lack of sleep can lead to overeating and
a diet with more sugar and caffeine and
this can lead to obesity type 2 diabetes
and cardiovascular disease the CDC says
one-third of adults do not get enough
sleep we would be and I believe that yep
dr. Carol Ashe is a sleep specialist
with RWJ barnabas health good morning
dr. Ashe thanks for being here this week
we talked about this story as much as we
talk about this story we can't talk
about it enough because it's a big
problem for us but explain the
connection between lack of sleep and how
that affects your diet so they looked at
500 women and they found with those 500
women those that had poor quality sleep
consumed sugary and processed foods 500
to 800 calories more a day of junk food
that increases your risk for heart
attack diabetes and obesity but why did
we do that the reason why is when you
don't get enough sleep at night it
alters the brain's ability to make good
food choices I experienced this all the
time yeah so you have no impulse control
and increased cravings for jumping well
nobody's craving a piece of lettuce or
celery okay why does it affect women
more than men well women because our
physiology being different we have the
menstrual cycle pregnancy and menopause
so there's we get all the funds we have
all the stuff but the risk is real for
men - mm-hmm and you know the other
thing that we've discovered is when you
don't sleep well at night it elevates
hormones that increase your appetite and
also the more sugary foods you eat it
actually triggers insomnia and that's
because you'll have blood sugar spikes
that will lead to increased adrenaline
that will cause restlessness during your
sleep so knowledge is willpower
hopefully what should people avoid
before bedtime well you know what you
want to make sure you just simply change
your diet so vegetables leafy greens
whole fruits you want to eat the
Mediterranean diet olives are good but
avoid the martini thoughts on how before
you go to sleep when you should stop
eating do you say an hour two hours or
does that matter did
does matter Gail so any alcoholic
beverages three hours before you go to
sleep at night and you really want to
start winding down about an hour before
bed at night and if you're finding
you're hungry at night a light snack so
such a protein or low sugar food so you
can have a yogurt a small yogurt or
whole wheat crackers with some turkey on
it something simple in life how do you
fight that when when you haven't had
enough sleep and we're in this situation
a lot and you get that urge because you
haven't had enough sleep how do you
battle that well the willpower the only
real solution is sleep so you know if
you if you're in a position where you
could take even a 20-minute nap it will
make all the difference and that that 20
minutes no more than 40 minutes because
if you go in longer than 40 minutes you
go into deep stages of sleep and you can
wake up groggy and confused but you know
even if you have to as a countermeasure
it was saving the caffeine for when you
feel sleepy but the best solution is
keeping a regular schedule keep the room
cool dark quiet at night and get your an
absolute nap so I can actually make it
20 minutes what do you think about the
sleep trackers that people use do you
think that those are effective they are
great to follow your progress so I use
it to show how much sleep I'm not
getting yeah what they do with them
unfortunately they have unrealistic
expectations of the sleep tracker and
then it causes performance anxiety then
they can't sleep at night so it's great
but don't have unrealistic expectations
you thumbs up or thumbs down on weighted
blankets we'll see do you know they do
help some people believe it or not yes
big supporter of weighted blanket thank
you very much